foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the view from
22 where we are going to be taking a
last look
at the ashes because as I'm sure many of
you know England won the last test at
the oval yesterday squaring the series
at tool Australia do however retain the
urn they keep the ashes
um and England will have to try and win
it back in Australia which will be a
very tall order in two years time I'm
joined for the Last Time by Henry
blofeld who has so kindly provided so
much brilliant commentary uh Henry thank
you very much for coming back I do
everything it's awfully sad isn't it
it's the last times it's really been
it's been an extraordinary Summer's
Cricket I mean it I don't think I've
ever I've watched something like seven
or eight hundred test matches and I
don't think I've ever sat through a
series as exciting as pulsating as this
one possibly one in the West Indies in
96 to 768 very long time ago
well I was actually I was going to ask
you was the 2005 series did you find it
more exciting than the 2005 series which
was pretty special well I suppose it's
easy and easy to say yes because it's
more immediate the memories are more
immediate
um yeah I think so uh in a way the first
test match in that series England were
bowled over by Ben McGraw and they and
um that was not a very exciting test
match uh I think generally I think this
the series had it I mean you never knew
session by session what was going to
happen you could not predict at all I
think the only thing that I got right in
the end was when Australia were 135 for
one yesterday morning I did say I'm
quite certain it's going to be a couple
of wickets or a dozen runs because it's
that sort of series and the funny thing
is once the series starts in that way it
goes on yes it's not the only thing
you've got right Henry because you also
said before the test the Old Trafford
which was sadly rained off or rained
into a draw uh you did say that the
English weather would stop us winning
the series 3-2 when we were two nil down
so you were you were bang on the money
there well I mean you could say at the
age of almost 84 it comes from
experience that I don't know that
there's any great expertise but it did
seem to be unlikely that we get through
hell summer without
um any interference but of course I mean
England really I think sort of would
have won that test and it would have
been free too which is extraordinary the
only 3-2 series of I was back in 36-7
when Gabby Allen said I lost won the
first two tests and lost the last three
that was in Australia
um I I feel that a draw was probably the
fair result uh even in spite of the rain
and Old Trafford because England
absolutely threw away the first test
match uh they dropped those catches Tony
Bear snow I don't know it was I knew he
did well well or did better with the
gloves increasingly uh whether it was a
wise toys at the start I'm not sure and
then of course at Lords 180 for one
England were on the second day with
Nathan Lyon the offspinner out of the
series with that calf muscle England
should have got 600 instead of which
they gave long leg catching brackets Yes
actually Nathan Lyon's injury when you
look back over the series could have
been very very important was it maybe a
little overlooked
um as to how much that limited the
Australians one can go as far as to say
would Australia have actually of won
series if lion had been there he's such
a good regular uh that that wouldn't
have been an impossibility not only is
he was he a wonderful bowline is a
wonderful bowler he's also a pretty
useful batsman as we saw in the closing
stages of the first test when he and the
Australian captains um come in uh put it
on all those runs at the end
um and and actually he looks about the
unathetic figure he's he's pretty handy
in the field as well
so I mean I think his his loss was huge
for Australia shall we talk about the
the story of the day it seems and that's
still broad uh who of course announced
his retirement
um the night before the last day of the
test uh and then it was almost written
in the stars that it would happen uh he
took the last two wickets uh and also
hit um his last ball in test Cricket for
six he does he does seem to have a
certain magic that I think puts him into
the Realms of greatness in The Cricket
in greatness do you think we can say
that I I think this is probably true
it's so difficult isn't it to compare
great past Builders now with what's gone
by in the past I think one could say
looking at the downside abroad that
perhaps he was a little bit inconsistent
were the times in Australia particularly
when he went for an awful lot of runs
and Greta didn't feature much in the
wickets uh but overall anyone would take
600 test wickets I mean it's absolutely
amazing and he has touched with magic I
mean I mean to get hit your last ball
will face the analysis test for six and
take a Wiggy with all the hospital the
next day is absolutely extraordinary and
all hails to him I mean tremendously
he's a subtle thoroughly decent bloke
and I mean he's not in the image of
old-fashioned fast brothers who were
always thought to be a bit basic weren't
they him to say nothing to say the least
I mean Broadus was absolutely
magnificent I thought and all credit to
him I did have one snake this sad moment
yesterday who actually
but when all this was going on and Broad
took the week it's pour out Jimmy
Anderson it is at the age of 41 a bit
too old probably he couldn't get it he
couldn't handle it he couldn't and the
greatest swing bowler ever but I'm
afraid he'd been neutered hadn't he he
simply couldn't find it and I did think
while broad was getting all their policy
and I thought poor oh Jimmy he shuffled
over into the England Brazil and
probably in a corner on his own I did I
had slightly the same uh thoughts
actually I thought in a way it's the
most cruel thing on Anderson because
broad has chosen to go out on an amazing
hide uh Jimmy now may not have the
choice as to whether he goes out on an
amazing eye or not because on current
form you probably have to drop him from
the from the test team oh I think you'll
certainly do I'm afraid yeah I mean
there may be an excuse next year if if
the wickets uh the weather turns and
it's absolutely ideal and the matches
don't travel there are circumstances
when you could see him coming back
um and it would be lovely to think that
he didn't take five wickets on his final
thing but at the moment it really does
look as though his day is done and what
I kept wondering was was he rather
regretting that he hadn't made a similar
decision to broads a little bit earlier
yes although it was he did quite
graciously he was one of the first to
actually congratulate Broadway
he's a great man Dave Jimmy won't let
wouldn't let that worry him I mean he'd
be they'll get it absolutely right in
that way I don't pull marks to him but I
mean it wasn't extraordinary day we've
we concentrate obviously on Broad but I
one of the features of yesterday was the
terrific slip catching of Zach Crawley
yeah and and he had an amazing Series in
that drawn test the Randolph test no
traffic that 189 was one of the great
Ash's Innings and he has shown laterally
more consistency than before a 73 here
was very good at the oval and I I I
think he's become a wonderful cricketer
and I think this is a great strength one
of the manifestations of the great
combined strengths of Stokes and
McCallum captain and manager they've
stuck by Crawley they perceived him to
be a match when are they perceived
exactly what he has produced and not
every every management team can do that
and I think that I think it that was
terrific and all credit to them and to
some extent would duck it too and ducky
didn't have quite the same as all the
series but there's two marvels in these
he played at Lords and he made a number
of very invaluable forties who are
making sure that Australia were looking
at 70 or 80 for no Wicked which is
always a lot of depressing for bowlers
yes well Andy they seem to have finally
cracked the riddle of the opening pair
for England now I think they know is
amazing isn't it up all the years we've
gone by as the cook could never find a
partner and before that you know it was
oh what can we do about the opening
position and so often sort of chapter
wouldn't fit in the middle order in
order to keep them in the side they all
pushed in at number two something that
never works and um yeah I agree I think
it's marvelous and I hope those two will
go on now uh for a year or two
I'm I'm looking ahead as as is my want
uh I know it's the long way away but I
can't help thinking having been slightly
robbed I think we could say uh in this
series maybe maybe that's a bit um no I
think I think that's a perfectly
reasonable thing I'm just saying that I
don't know you will you can argue it the
other way and say that if we'd hang on
to the catches at Edwardson we wouldn't
be having this conversation because the
ashes would be safely in our keeping yes
but I do you think perhaps uh we might
manage to to rob the Australians uh in a
a year and a three quarters a year and a
half's time it's very very difficult to
win in Australia you know
um I wonder I tell you what I was
thinking not only yesterday but
Manchester I went watching um crawleys
and he's 189 how are you going to cope
with the higher bands on Australian
how's ducky it's going to go
um it's interesting some people come
through that test wonderfully well other
very good England batsmen all down the
edges have gone to Australia with great
great records and have come back
empty-handed entirely empty-handed
almost having played their last test
match I mean it there have been
significant failures because the high
bounce the Steep bonds does Undo
techniques that have been honed only in
England without any thoughts
um to other Behavior but behavior of the
ball that is
explain that a little bit more for us
is that because a Batson like Crawley
likes to hit the ball on the art
he likes to hit it on the up when the
ball bounds it comes through probably a
little bit quicker and when it it's
bouncing that a bit much higher uh
you've got to you've got to play later I
think
um and and and I yeah I'm quite sure
he's got the ability to really adapt to
it I I can't answer that and I won't be
able to until I see him in Australia but
this higher Bounce has undone some very
good very good England players in the
past
do you think it might also undo another
brilliantly talented uh attacking
batsman in Harry Brook
um I I think Harry I think Harry Brook
is less likely to be undone by high buns
uh than he is by his own character I'm
not certain Harry Brook at the moment
doesn't think he he's all a little bit
too easy he's good I'm not certain how
that he is that good no I mean his
necklace wrong he's very very good but
I'm not quite certain he's as good as he
thinks he is I mean you saw him come in
at the oval and he about his fourth ball
he bumps down the Wicket and hit Murphy
for a straight six it was a supremely
confident shot for a bathroom who has
been around for a long time before
travel's Ready News that new to test
Cricket it was amazing and then he
played a bit of wet shot outside the old
stump in the next level the next level
one and was caught behind
um I think he's got a little bit to go
he's got to quieten himself down and
realize that the game perhaps isn't
quite as easy as he thinks it is at the
moment I mean he had that amazing
thought didn't he in the Pakistan and
then New Zealand last winter and
Australia are a different cattle Affairs
and he'll he'll understand that too but
he's got such talent my money would be
on the fact that he will make he will
make it work for him and I would back
him being an intelligent chapter she
obviously is I would back him uh to cope
with the High bands in Australia
and what about our bowling attack in
Australia obviously we'll be without
broad uh we'll almost certainly be
without Jimmy Anderson
um we've have some useful quick Bowlers
now we have wood we have tongue uh we
have Robinson they won't mentioned the
best one works works works 19 wickets
and three test matches I thought looked
absolutely wonderful I think he's
building's got uh somewhere to go too I
mean I think he's he's a really exciting
prospect what what the trouble with wood
is when he's on song when he played in
that first test that heading he was
terrific he's always been injury prone
and uh he had a bruised heel in this I
know that sounds a sort of trivial
injury but if you were passed by the
original isn't
um he does get injured and I wonder
quite where that's going to leave him as
far as the futurist concerned yes tongue
was a great Prospect wasn't he when he
came in for that match and he bowled
Jolly well and he's obviously I would
think he's going to go on tour and next
year in England we'll see much more of
him because now I was broad going and
Anderson's got to go I think uh there's
going to be more space for people like
done to come in
um we've got an opening power we've now
got to find another pair of opening
photos because we
've done yeah uh well you're quite right
to pick me up on works because I think
yesterday probably third say he he was
really the key man obviously broad took
uh the plaudits and perhaps rightly so
but wokes took the crucial wickets
didn't he well he took he took he he did
two things he got the openers out he got
uh worn out and caught behind didn't he
then um kawaja lbw with a beauty I
thought and then he got um of course he
got Steve Smith out yeah and Steve Smith
said I thought it's hard stroke he'd
been there two and a half hours working
really hard and suddenly he seemed to me
that I watched that he he half lost
concentration I don't know
um it wasn't it wasn't a Smith stroke
but this is a great beauty of the game
of cricket uh nothing can be guaranteed
yes
and uh there's a there's a theory on
works that he doesn't Bowl so well
abroad do you think is is that valid or
do you think he will develop into a
useful player on on different well I
think having taken the 19 wickets he
took here in this series and he's now
been on a winning side against Australia
which he's never been before I think
he'll his confidence is so important I
think I think now he's going to be a
different man when he next takes on
Australia in Australia too and I would
think that he's going he's going I would
think he's going to get better
I mean I think he's very good as it is
but I think he will get better I think
he's got uh he's got such good control
he's of everything and
um I I'm very very impressed with him
and I was also very impressed with him
as a batsman I mean we saw how good he
was as a lure or lower middle order
player in at heading there I mean that
lovely Square Drive will start to win
the match it was beautiful stroke
um no I think I think he's got a big
future to play and I personally think
that he's got all the talents to um to
conquer anything he comes up against
well Henry I'm going to end by asking
you to to make an impossible prediction
because as as discussed it's a long way
ahead uh and there's lots of cricket
both sides will play in in between
um and both sides will develop and
change and the Australians have this
amazing habit of discovering
outrageously great talents a very short
notice
um but do you think we will beat uh
Australia in the next sashes
it's a very difficult question I think
the answer to that I shall say yes on
the basis of this if Ben Stokes is fit
enough to lead us I think his
inspiration in the dressing room in the
hotel in on out on the field is enormous
and really mustn't be underestimated if
Stokes is not I don't think we will win
though and perhaps he might be able to
bowl a bit more
well they I believe he others talk about
an operation and everything he's in his
30s Now isn't He's 33 I think
um yes I I I I I I I hope so because
he's he has the ability to get good bats
for now suddenly and he comes on and
gets them in both of them at this a bit
too didn't he and um
uh but Stokes in the other batsman he's
such a he's such a powerful Factor too I
think he's an amazing I think he's an
amazing cricketer and when you think and
I I say this in no way detrimentally but
when you think he got into a bit of
trouble didn't in the Embargo nightclub
a few years ago yeah I retired in 2017.
I mean I hadn't he material I'd be on
the belief into a very very formidable
figure and one of the great test
captains I really think you can say that
no well on that uh positive note we will
end it but uh Henry I would like to say
finally thank you so much for coming on
spectated TV I know our viewers have
been uh very grateful for your insights
and um I've enjoyed it enormously I mean
it's very kind we'll get a a a like me
out in front of the camera again and I
really loved it thank you very much for
having me absolutely not since we've
been lucky to have you so uh thanks
again and um see you perhaps for the
next uh test series
[Music]